check the white king now because the
white queen covers any square the black
rook wants to check from so black's
queen is the only one which can give
check
you have to keep giving check because if
you give the move to white white is
going to checkmate the black king and
here we go there's no way to continue
the attack
i think this is going to head to try
i've personally i i think this is one of
the most impressive prague games i've
seen um not necessarily from the way
played the opening or the early middle
game but when his position started to
look difficult the way he played
so accurately lots of people would
crumble but he's he's he's played this
uh
so well from a tricky position
um gonna see a result any moment now wei
yi looks resigned to the fact that this
game is going to be a draw and prague is
going through to the semi-finals black
has nothing else to do you have to give
checks to avoid checkmate and there we
go third time we've seen this position
it's over a marathon match between these
two ends up with pragma number the 16
year old making it through to the
semi-final